hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
at the very end of David hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding there is
a passage which is some really great
rhetoric and has drawn reader's
attention for you know now more than two
centuries it's actually been
encapsulated into something that Hume
didn't say and didn't call it called
Humes fork and a lot of use has been
made out of it this is probably the
passage that people best know of Hume uh
the only other Contender would be that
reason is and can never be other than
the slave of the passions we're going to
put that aside for the moment although
that would be an interesting one to
throw into the hopper of hume's fork
would it not so Hume doesn't call it
hume's Fork it's only later philosophers
interpreting it who are going to do that
sort of like with anselms ontological
argument which he doesn't call an
ontological argument and the part that
we do call the ontological argument
isn't the whole of the argument that he
references in the Pro slogan but you
know that's kind of common in the
history of ideas
so how does this passage run Hume says
when we run over libraries persuaded of
these principles the things that he said
already what Havoc must we make if we
take in our hand any volume of divinity
or School of metaphysics for instance
let us ask now here's where the actual
Fork comes up
does it contain any abstract reasoning
concerning quantity or number no
does it contain any experimental
reasoning concerning matter of fact and
existence no commit it then to the
Flames for it can contain nothing but
sophistry and illusion so you know what
we're seeing here is that humans saying
when it comes to books and it doesn't
have to be just books you know as he's
using these as examples of divinity or
School of metaphysics it could be any
book whatsoever it could be a pamphlet
it could be an argument that's made on a
TV show it could be anything you like
if it doesn't contain either you know
relations of ideas or uh you know
experimental reasoning about matters of
fact and existence then it's got no
meaning or value whatsoever and we throw
it in the Flames because it contains
only sophistry and illusion now notice
some of the things that Hume is saying
here that a lot of people miss out on
he's not saying that if there's any book
that contains any portion that is not
relation of ideas and matters of fact it
could have like a mixture right of
relations of ideas matters of fact and
then other stuff that doesn't fit into
either of those he's not saying throw
that out he might be cool with getting
rid of that section
as we're going to see there's there's
some interesting
cases that we're going to have to look
at in a moment that you know maybe we
don't want to throw these out either or
maybe we do
notice what else Hume is not saying In
this passage or even in this section he
is not using the terms analytic or
synthetic as later philosophers from
Kant onward really when it comes to this
matter have been he's not using the
terms a postiori and a priori you might
say wait a second I saw a a reference to
ah priori in there yes but Hume is not
calling relations of ideas a priori he
is actually talking about matters of
fact and saying that we could come up
with a priori reasonings about them now
to be fair Hume does in fact use these
terms
Opera in other parts of his works but
the identification of relations of ideas
and matters of fact with that is you
know that's something coming about later
on it's not
anti-hume but it's not contained right
there in this section now
what do we mean by relations of ideas
here's where we actually have to be a
little bit careful not just to think we
know exactly what Hume means and to buy
into what's in effect a slogan but we
need to look at what he's actually
telling us here so we back up a little
bit into part three of section 12. he
says to me it seems to me
the only objects of the abstract
Sciences or of demonstration are
quantity and number all attempts to
extend this more perfect species of
knowledge Beyond these bounds are mere
sophistry and illusion so we see that
sophistry and illusion coming up there
hold on to that for a second he tells us
as the component parts of quantity and
number are entirely similar their
relations become intricate and involved
nothing can be more curious as well as
useful than to trace their equality or
inequality through their different
appearances but as all other ideas are
clearly distinct and different from each
other we can never Advance further by
the our most utmost scrutiny than to
observe this diversity and by an obvious
reflection pronounced one thing to be
another so it's because numbers and we
could say you know maybe even functions
geometric shapes and uh
properties and stuff like that they're
all sort of basically interchange
changeable we can actually make progress
when it comes to matters of quantity and
number that we can't when it comes to
other things
and then he says something really
interesting he's talking about other
matters now this is where later
interpreters influenced by Hume for
example The Logical positives think
about AJ air
would say well wait a second you know
what else fits into this whatever we
want to call it you know analytics
statements relations of ideas you know
definitions of things a bachelor is an
unmarried male is defining Bachelor
saying how we use our language it's it's
you know it's true by virtue of the
meanings of the terms and him doesn't
want to include that here he doesn't
want to give that the status of
mathematics
he he's cool with doing that in terms of
um you know things like square of
hypotenuse equal to the square of the
two other sides right but he says to
convince us of the proposition that
where there is no property there can be
no Injustice coming from Thomas Hobbes
right
um it is only necessary to define the
terms and explain Injustice to be a
violation of property the proposition is
indeed nothing but a more imperfect
definition and he says it's the same
case with all those pretended
syllogistic reasonings which may be
found in every branch of learning except
the Sciences of quantities of number
these Sciences of quantity and number
may be pronounced the only objects of
knowledge and demonstration Okay so
we've got relations of ideas on one side
which are really just going to be about
mathematics
whatever we can mathematize what about
this other side matters of fact and
existence very very important right
says all other inquiries of human beings
regard only matter of fact and existence
these are incapable of demonstration
the most you can ever have with these is
probability
and the probability can be very very
high
but you could never be a hundred percent
certain why he says whatever is may not
be no negation of a fact can involve a
contradiction the non-existence of any
being without exception is as clear and
distinct an idea as its existence the
proposition which affirms it to be is
not to be however false is no less
conceivable and intelligible than that
which affirms it to be and he says the
case is different with the Sciences
properly so-called you know so that
we're back in relations of fact now he's
talking about mathematics so he says the
existence of any being
can only be proved by arguments from its
cause or its effect
these are based entirely on experience
if we reason now here we see the term a
priori show up if we reason our priori
anything may appear able to produce
anything the falling of a pebble May for
all we know extinguish the Sun or the
wish of a man control the planets in
their orbits so whenever whenever we're
engaging in sort of a priori not you
know connected to experience reasoning
about things that are not number or uh
you know quantity
we are going out into the realm of
imagination of things could be this way
or this way but we don't really know one
way or the other and so he says it's
only experience which teaches us the
nature and Bounds of cause and effect
and enables us to infer the existence of
one object from the other this is the
foundation of what he calls moral
reasoning right
um which isn't just about ethics it's
about all the things that could be
probable all the things that we are
concerned with in life which forms the
greater part of human knowledge and as a
source of all human action and behavior
so relations of ideas really cool we can
you know know them for certain if we can
figure out the proofs but matters of
fact are much more important they're the
majority of what we are concerned with
and so he goes on and he tells us that
moral reasonings so matters of fact and
existence
are concerning either particular or
general facts and this is where we get
to different kinds of
disciplines you could say all the
liberations in life he says regard the
former particular should I eat this food
or should I save it for later should I
take this job or should I take a
different job should I you know tie my
shoes or walk around with my shoelaces
untied right those are kind of ordinary
life things he also says all of history
chronology
geography interesting though the measure
of the Earth
and notice what else he says and
astronomy are about particular facts
what about General facts he says well
that's politics natural philosophy
physics chemistry Etc where the
qualities causes and effects of a whole
species of objects are inquired into and
you can say well why then is astronomy
and geography not in there well because
they're being understood in terms of
like the particularities of the star
you're looking at if we subsume you know
astronomy into physics and we get
astrophysics then we're not so worried
about that star as a particular star
we're worried about stars in general
right you see how this this works
so these are a number of different
Sciences we've got mathematics geometry
whatever else is in there on that side
logic you could say and then we have all
the things that are ordinary life and
all the other Sciences here in matters
of fact and existence
what else is there though he discusses
two other important domains
one is Divinity or theology right
he says as it proves the existence of a
deity and the immortality of souls is
composed partly of reasonings concerning
particular partly concerning General
facts
but
it has a foundation and reason insofar
as it is supported by experience
does it actually have a foundation and
reason supported by experience not
according to Hume not according to what
he said prior to that but there's an out
he says
um it's best and most solid foundation
is Faith and divine revelation right
which is not part of the relations of
ideas also not matters of fact and
existence it's something else
and so that would be something that
maybe if human's not going to throw out
the whole book maybe he'd throw it the
parts of the book that are concerned
with faith right he's leaving that as a
conclusion for us to draw what about and
this is very interesting matters of what
he calls morals and criticism he says
these are not so properly objects of the
understanding as of taste and sentiment
sentiment meaning feeling Beauty whether
moral or natural is more is felt more
properly than perceived or if we reason
concerning it and Endeavor to fix the
standard we regard a new fact and what
is that new fact the taste of humankind
so if we look at Aesthetics and ethics
in terms of what people do in fact think
or feel to be good or beautiful well
we're doing kind of like a sociology of
taste at that point that can be matters
of fact we can't actually say that
things are indeed beautiful like in
themselves with you know a kind of
capital b beauty all we can say is well
this is regarded as beautiful by these
people and they here's the reasons that
they give we can't actually declare
ourself on that right so
when we run over our libraries Divinity
morals criticism those are the ones who
might be placed on the chopping block
right we can also say nonsense books
like you know Lewis Carroll's uh stories
you know where things happen that
couldn't you know can't don't really
work out perhaps maybe that goes into
this as well or who knows right but uh
hume's Fork is actually a little bit
less forceful than people often make it
out to be it's not saying listen all you
have possibly are relations of ideas or
matters of fact and existence nothing
else can possibly be expressed or exist
right it's not saying that
because we do have you know Divinity
which is based on faith or morals and
criticism based on taste and sentiment
or perhaps some other things that are
sophistry and illusion right even
sophistry and illusion are something
it's the saying well we need to divide
things into these and then anything that
doesn't contain at least some of this
get rid of it that's you know what the
the statement is actually saying many
people have interpreted this in other
ways that go a little bit against hume's
text as we've already talked about but
that is in effect if you want to call it
hume's Fork this is the passage that
it's coming from and this is the basic
idea behind it